y directo a América lo continuamos con
las noticias económicas de la mano de
Daniela hablandon Ramírez Daniela Buenas
noches bienvenida Hola María Clara
Buenos días y empezamos Buenas noches
empezamos hablando de Europa porque se
reunieron los principales líderes de
este continente para hablar de temas
energéticos Así es específicamente
representantes de nueve países europeos
que discutieron la creación de la mayor
central energética verde en el mar del
Norte El objetivo es instalar una red de
plantas de energía eólica Marina capaz
de abastecer a más de 300 millones de
hogares en 2050 este proyecto se discute
en momentos de tensión por el aumento de
los precios de los combustibles en medio
de la guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania y
cuando los países europeos buscan
afanosamente reducir su dependencia del
petróleo ruso la Unión Europea tiene la
meta de Elevar al 42,5% la cuota de
consumo de energía renovable en 2030
frente al 22%
actual
se trata de tener un enfoque coherente y
decir que queremos que la industria
europea produzca no queremos repetir los
errores del pasado cuando por ejemplo
desplegamos paneles solares a gran
escala e importamos mucho eso nos brinda
una oportunidad de resiliencia soberanía
y un enfoque Made In europe en el que
creemos
y en Alemania sin embargo está agitado
el panorama laboral pues el fin de
semana los trabajadores del sector
público llegaron a un acuerdo con el
gobierno para no ir a huelga también
hace una semana varios aeropuertos
pararon operaciones y para este
miércoles está convocado un ser un cc
ferroviario hoy el turno es para el
personal en Tierra aeroportuario de dos
importantes aeropuertos que adelantan
una huelga de 24 horas reclamando
mejoras en sus condiciones salariales y
también que le reconozcan otros
beneficios adicionales además de la
parálisis en el aeropuerto de Hamburgo
la capital Berlín tuvo que cancelarlo
cerca de 240 vuelos programados Paraguay
las demandas concretas tienen que ver
con mejoras en bonificaciones por
ejemplo se trata del trabajo nocturno en
cuanto a los tiempos en cuanto a los
porcentajes también de las horas extras
que son muy importantes si tienes que
trabajar más horas en los viajes aéreos
Qué tipo de bonos habrá hemos estado
tratando de mejorar lo relacionado con
todas esas bonificaciones durante varios
años con los empleador y todo esto
sucede mientras el Banco Central de
Alemania asegura que en el primer
trimestre de la economía pudo haber
crecido levemente Y esto es bastante
importante porque esquiva la recesión
Aunque la inflación anual Sí todavía
está cerca del 9% y de las huelgas en
Alemania pasamos a una quiebra en
Estados Unidos de una marca bastante
reconocida sobre productos para el hogar
Cuál es pues es la reconocida marca
Beyond uno de los grandes fabricantes de
sábanas toallas y otros productos para
el hogar que dijo que iniciará una
liquidación ordenada de sus negocios
esto después de no poder seguir a flote
luego de años de pérdidas y caídas en
ventas además de numerosos planes de
recuperación fallidos el cierre de sus
tiendas afectaría a unos 14.000
trabajadores directos a no ser que antes
del 30 de junio consiga un comprador de
todos o algunos de sus negocios que
comprenden 360 locales de Bed y unos 120
sitios de bye Baby por ahora sus sitios
web si permanecerán abiertos Daniela y
qué indicadores nos tiene para comenzar
esta semana pues Wall Street quien cerró
mixto allí una de las noticias del día
tuvo que ver con el banco First uno de
los más castigados en la reciente crisis
que hoy reveló que sus depósitos en el
primer trimestre se redujeron en más del
40% y también que va a recortar entre el
20 y el 25% de su planta de personal las
bolsas europeas terminaron en rojo en
una semana en la que habrá múltiples
revelaciones de resultados financieros
hoy por ejemplo la tecnológica Philips
saltó
13,8%, tras publicar muy buenos
resultados trimestrales y en América
Latina México tuvo su mejor Cierre en
dos semanas tras conocerse que la
inflación de la primera quincena de
abril se desaceleró por sexto mes
consecutivo ahora va en el 6,24% y la
cifra de este lunes va a ser positiva o
negativa va a ser negativo para Los
amantes de la coca-cola no sé si usted
está entre ellos yo no personalmente
entre ellas pero cuénteme pues mire 11%
aumentaron en promedio los precios de
los productos de esta multinacional en
el primer trimestre Mientras tanto súper
rival histórico pepsico congeló los
precios en este primer trimestre también
Y es que El fabricante de refrescos como
fanta y Sprite facturó más de 10 mil
millones de dólares y ganó más de 3 mil
millones de dólares más de lo que
esperaba el mercado debido no solamente
al alza de precios sino al alza de la
demanda y reconoció algo muy particular
Es que la turbulencia bancaria está
teniendo cierto efecto sobre las
decisiones de consumo en Europa y eso
relativamente ha venido bajando sus
ventas en esa lugar del mundo Daniela
Gracias por todas las noticias
económicas nos vemos mañana